my sister  Jess and I we're identical twins when  something happens to one of us the other  one can tell it's hard to explain but I  can just feel it  she's in trouble and she needs me your  sister went into a Hokie kajada forest  it's where lost people go to commit  suicide I'm coming dear  I'm looking for my sister when in the  forest I wanna hire a guy nobody forest  is very dangerous spirits cannot rest  there they come back angry  I can't let you go in by yourself I have  clearance to go in with the garden I  could ask if you could come the forest  is very dangerous do not leave the path  oh my god that's right tag yeah yeah you  cannot stay after dark I'm not leaving  without my sister at night people see  bad things you get paranoid  we're not real  ananza deonda Van Zeeland the other  nasty some constant C here Cassie see  Boston together